je suis vraiment contente que tu sois là
je veux tu passes un bon week end
c'est ça
caen pour
dun koudrik en acadie
[Musique]
tu vas devoir me rend pas les tout ça
j'ai pas encore pris mon café
excuse moi
joe jordan
il suffit que tu regarde ta mère épouse
moi d'accord
mais tu sauras ce que je veux dire par
beauté
c'est ton père qui a écrit ça
il a écrit ce jour des réacs pourtant
d'après une histoire vraie
[Musique]
l'amour est un choix du thème
et le véritable amour
requiert le sens de sacrifice
mais la douleur est momentanée
le véritable amour dure toujours
et souviens-toi journal
tu dois te battre pour le garder
[Musique]